ja wer in diesen tagen sein spülmittel
sucht im supermarkt der kommt ja nicht
vorbei an den bergen von spekulatius
dominosteine und lebkuchen die
vorweihnachtszeit ist da und die
vorweihnachtszeit erkennt man auch daran
dass demnächst wieder die
weihnachtsmärkte ihre pforten eröffnet
werden in den innenstädten deutschlands
aber in vielen städten deutschlands
diesmal unter ganz besonderen
bedingungen einlass nur für geimpfte und
frisch genesenen in erfurt weiter zu
sein in mannheim in mainz in duisburg in
berlin wird es weihnachtsmärkte nur für
unter zwei bedingungen geben der
erfurter oberbürgermeister hat gesagt
man sei bemüht den leuten das alte leben
zurückzubringen deswegen werde die 2g
regelung gelten ich bin schon alt genug
ich erinnere mich noch an das alte leben
und da gab es einfach keine
weihnachtsmärkte mit 2g regelung zweig
ist diskriminierung immer und besonders
an weihnachtsmärkten nach zwei überhaupt
nichts suchen wir erinnern uns
vielleicht dunkel noch daran weihnachten
da geht es um nächstenliebe da geht es
um familie für christen geht es um die
geburt von christie und wer dort eben
von christus und wer dort eben zweig
regelungen ein fördert von weihnachten
nicht verstanden wer unbedingt unter
zwei
veranstaltungen unter freien himmel
veranstalten möchte der sollte
vielleicht den titel ändern und nicht
von weihnachtsmärkten sprechen sondern
von winterlichen verkaufsveranstaltungen
für frisch genesene und geimpfte das
wäre meine forderung aber bitte nicht
weihnachten
alexander ich kann dir nur zustimmen ich
frage mich ja schon seit längerem ob
deutschen eigentlich der weltmeister im
ausgrenzen werden wenn also während
andere länder immer freier werden und
auch schon in fremde ausgerufen werden
werden wir immer und freier und das mit
zweig ich finde es furchtbar ich gehe
auch nicht in restaurants mit zweig
außerdem seien sie im notfall aber sonst
nicht und da muss man ganz klar sagen
wir müssen auf ein menschen auszugrenzen
das ist auch nicht gut für die stimmung
in unserem land deswegen ich finde das
großartig und kann es nur unterstützt
und wenn jetzt auch noch einsatz dazu
wenn es gerade auch der michael
kretschmer immerhin der sächsische
ministerpräsident gesagt hat zweig sei
nun ein zwingendes muss dann ist das
natürlich ein satz der eben eine debatte
eröffnet die noch spalterische und noch
ausgrenzung der werte nation erhitzten
gesellschaft man kann darüber gerne
diskutieren aber zu sagen sei ein
zwingendes muss jene leute die sich
bisher nicht impfen haben lassen können
oder wollen von wesen bestandteilen der
sozialen teilhabe und das kulturellen
miteinanders auszuschließen das ist und
bleibt einfach diskriminieren aber ich
fand kretschmer immerhin ehrlich gesagt
zweig es dann muss man bislang wird uns
erzählt seit wochen naja es ist ja total
freiwillig wie sich ein betrieb
entscheidet zwischen 3g oder in zweige
das ist die entscheidung des betriebs
aber man macht ja mannschaft handy
anreize dafür dass betriebe es möglichst
attraktiv finden auf zweig umzustellen
sonst würden die das ja nicht machen wer
in cafés geht der findet dort ja keiner
was nicht überzeugungstäter keine
radikale öko witt aktivisten sondern die
sagen einfach ich krieg mehr leute rein
wenn ich zwei auf zweig umstellen kann
wenn die leute nicht mehr maske tragen
müssen wir nicht die tische näher
beieinander stellen kann deswegen
stellen die leute darauf um da reden wir
aber immer von innenräumen eine
weihnachtsmesse unter freiem himmel das
ist über sein auto sehr sehr gering und
bildschön passkontrolle beim einlass zum
weihnachtsmarkt also ihr kinderlein
kommet aber nur wenn er geimpft sein
liebe deinen nächsten
wie dich selbst
wir haben einen relativ kurzen
weihnachtsmarkt ein wochenende mit drei
tagen also wir reden jetzt ja
wahrscheinlich auf den weihnachtstagen
dieser vier wochen gehen und so wissen
was anderes und er ist mitten in der
altstadt infolgedessen kommt somit
einlasskontrolle eigentlich nicht in
betracht weil die bürger wollen ja auch
noch zu ihrer wohnung wir haben noch
nicht ganz entschieden wie wir das
machen aber ich tendiere zu 3g und zwar
aufgrund der baden-württembergischen
corona verordnung die dann keine
einlasskontrolle verlangt es scheint
anders zu sein bei stellen die sie
zitiert also mannheim macht es dann weil
es will aber nicht weil es die korona
verordnung verlangt also keine
einlasskontrollen die stadt selbst ist
aber in den konsumbereich also wo man
trinken und essen kann da ist dann quasi
wenn sie ins lokal gehen würden ist dann
3g pflicht das halte ich für eine ganz
gute lösung weil in der tat so beim
herumlaufen was solltest aber wenn ich
jetzt leuten gegenüber bin dann da isst
und trinkt was getragen kann man auch
schlecht in ihrem sinne da finde ich es
jetzt nicht falsch wenn ich weiß um mich
herum sind leute die immer wieder
getestet oder gibt wer kontrolliert das
sie dann auf dem banner das machen wir
dann über sicherheitspersonal was für
die stadt bezahlt leute ja gut auf den
weihnachtsmann kontrollieren an den an
denen
im bestimmen
aber warum mit blick auf die aktuelle
impfquoten auch die aktuellen genesung
seien also ich frage mich das wirklich
als bürgerin wozu brauchen wir jetzt
noch die maßnahmen warum kann man nicht
den weihnachtsmann in tübingen an den
drei tagen einfach für alle offen machen
also erstmal die legistische methode
weil das land baden württemberg ist so
vorschreibt es gibt dabei wir sind der
grünen ja natürlich hat nicht alleine
aber das macht eine verordnung muss mich
daran halten egal und inhaltlich würde
ich im moment sagen wenn ich mir die
situation in yucatán cook das ist wohl
doch so ist dass wir wegen der erhöhten
ansteckungsgefahr durch dell tagen noch
nicht übern berg sie und dass es sich
lohnt vorsichtig zu sein wenn es die
lebensqualität nicht zu sehr einschränkt
und auch die die gesellschaft nicht
spaltet und ich finde ein angebot wo
jeder hin kann aber man halt weist da
ist einen risikoschutz das ist noch okay
das würde ich diesen winter noch
aushalten die tester nach
kostenpflichtig in tübingen sein für den
es regelt das regeln wir noch übrigens
ist 2 geht deswegen gar nicht so
relevant weil die leute seid die tests
geld kosten von kaffee natürlich keine
15 euro also real macht es kaum
unterschiede ja sagen die gastronoms
kommt eigentlich niemand mehr mit 3g
also mit getestet weil da muss ich ja
vorher für geld testen lassen das lohnt
sich nicht aber wir werden versuchen das
in der weihnachtszeit mit dem
christlichen gedanken der nächstenliebe
wieder kostenlos anzubieten ja also für
mich ist für mich ist eigentlich zweig
nur unter einem aspekt
akzeptabel wenn das mit gut gelaunt
übersetzt wird sonst würde ich sagen wie
du hast so weiter und ich glaube ich
einfach bei diesen 2g 3g
frage ich mich einfach entspricht das
eigentlich noch der verfassung dem
grundgesetz in deutschland also in der
schweiz haben wir eine riesen diskussion
jetzt nicht aus der fringe ecke da
sondern vor namhaftesten staus rechnen
die sorgen dass die zertifikate pflicht
in der schweiz das geht übrigens weiter
als in deutschland also wo man sich bei
einem teilnahme am sozialen leben muss
man ein zertifikat vorweisen auch in
verbindung mit einer mitteilung aus weiß
dass dies gegen die nichtdiskriminierung
das nicht diskriminierungs artikel in
der bundesverfassung
später spricht und das ist auch dem
recht auf bewegungsfreiheit in der
schweiz widerspricht und wir haben die
zu eine ganz intensive diskussion mit
blick auf eine volksabstimmung wo sich
also wirklich rechtsprofessoren
universität zürich freiburg bern
eingeschaltet haben die gesagt haben
dass sie eigentlich eine art
latenter verfassungsbruch stattfinde und
dieses gesetz das das dann verbriefen
soll unsere verfassungsordnung
widerspricht und das finde ich hier
einig die ganz spannende frage inwiefern
hat sich diese cupid pandemie unseren
politischen verselbständigt dass man
daraus jetzt war sie einschränkungen
ableitet die gar nicht mehr gedeckt sind
durch die verfassung aber dann das
zeichen heute also dass die
ampelkoalition sagt wir beenden diese
notstandsgesetzgebung in drei wochen das
finde ich extrem wichtig weil die sorge
man richtet sich das gemütliche eigene
obrigkeitsstaat und macht immer weiter
die hatten viele ich habe auch schon
artikel geschrieben und es wird mir
jetzt langsam zu bunt und dass sie jetzt
klar gesagt haben wir machen dann nicht
weiter das finde ich manchmal wir haben
in deutschland im unterschied zur
schweiz am bundesverfassungsgericht und
das hat sich bis jetzt nicht durch eine
sozusagen eine extreme energie
hervorgetan sie sagen ja möglichen
verstöße durch eine gemütliche
abendessen mit der kanzlerin womöglich
ich weiß es nicht aber es hat zumindest
ein geschmäckle und jetzt wird für
oktober november die entscheidung und
die bundes notbremse angekündigt hätte
man auch schon mal vorher machen können
vielleicht sogar
schon sehr spannender punkt da gibt es
auch verschiedene punkte wo man ganz
klar sie das ist etwas ist etwas
schwierig warum beispielsweise alle
anträge
auf die ausgangssperren einfach noch
entschieden wurden ich muss hier noch
den ganzen aus meiner sicht
entscheidende punkt reinbringen warum
macht man das ganze möchte ja die leute
dazu bringen dass sie sich impfen lassen
und das habe ich eine umfrage gesehen in
deutschland zwei drittel der ungeimpften
haben gesagt sie würden sich unter
keinen umständen impfen lassen als es
auch in die impfung sei aus ihrer sicht
um sicher langzeitfolgen und die
wirksamkeit sei nicht bekannt dass heißt
mit diesen erzieherischen maßnahmen
bringt man diesen hardcore und zwei
drittel umgehen wie bringt man gar nicht
dazu dass man die in die impfung nötigen
können das muss man nur sagen man muss
auch akzeptieren wenn sich leute eine
bestimmte medizinische behandlung nicht
unterziehen wollen der staat darf nicht
in die körpersäfte der menschen hinein
regieren
es gab auch im oktober schon eine
umfrage unter ungeimpften unter haben
über 70 gesagt dass sie sich also dass
die sicherheitsbedenken haben und über
60 prozent haben gesagt dass sie sich
auch schon aus trotz nicht impfen lassen
wollen und ich glaube spätestens da
hätte die bundesregierung erkennen
müssen gerade auch im osten deutschlands
wo diese politische trotzreaktion aus
historischen gründen sehr gut
nachvollziehbar ist druck funktioniert
nicht und man hat noch mal auf druck
gesetzt man hat den menschen das blaue
vom himmel versprochen man hat gesagt
sobald jeder ein angebot hatte nehmen
wir die maßnahmen zurück als jeder ein
angebot hatte wollte man davon nichts
mehr wissen und man hat stattdessen auf
druck gesetzt auf zweig auf schelte über
die medien und sonstwas und es geht
einfach und eben vor allem das finde ich
eben sehr sehr problematisch
institutionen die staatlich und damit
unser aller geld finanziert werden
fordert vorreiter sind weiter zweig
bewegung die elbphilharmonie in hamburg
wissenschaftskolleg in berlin viele
opernhäuser die also von unser aller
geld für soziale kulturelle teilhabe und
bildung bezahlt werden und die sind nun
ganz vorne dabei diese zweig regeln
einzuführen
ok und dadurch werden eben dann momentan
sind 77 prozent der volljährigen
vollständig geimpft das heißt aber
immerhin noch über 20 prozent werden von
der möglichkeit der teilhabe
ausgeschlossen müssen aber dafür
bezahlen wir werden das corona problem
heute nicht mehr gelöst kriegen hier
eine wüste